so we can't be boots on the ground at e3
this year but the gm of call of duty
johannes ferris has kindly agreed
to come join us and talk about
everything cod thank you so much for
joining us
thanks for having me super happy to be
here so it's only a few years ago that
call of duty was a singular
beast and now it's more of a
multi-headed hydra of of war zone the
annual release
call of duty mobile and it's on people's
radar all year round
not during peak season anymore so who's
playing
all of these versions is there much
crossover or have you sort of
seen sort of individual markets taking
on each type of game
yeah i think it's it's really an
interesting time for the franchise to
your point because it's expanded
at such scale so quickly you know you
think about what happened
not just with the premium releases doing
what they've done but here comes mobile
here comes warzone and now you have a
whole new vr component to the community
and it's just been a really interesting
exercise i think
in how to transform the franchise it's
never been stronger in many ways so when
you ask like who's playing
clearly we've seen a floodgate open
as far as new you know entrance into the
system
beyond what we were traditionally known
for with the
core mp predominantly or campaign-driven
types of experiences prior to those
releases that i mentioned and you also
see new regions
in the globe that have opened up i think
mobile has done a tremendous job sort of
lighting
call of duty up in all these different
ways in in regions where maybe we
weren't as as dominant
prior to just given the platform
strategy that
can scale in different parts of the
world now with the same ap
so it's really amazing you know i think
we have cross pollination
we also have these sort of region
specific
identities that have emerged given that
growth that i mentioned
and the franchise in many ways i think
is undergoing sort of a renaissance
to really consider ourselves differently
who are we as a mega brand
who do we appeal to uh in
in ways that maybe have created new
new vectors for us and it's really about
connecting more players all over the
world
removing the barriers making it easy to
drop it and play call of duty the way
you like to play it with you and with
your friends right
i'm glad you mentioned the vr aspect
because warzone is
really a pillar of that genre do you
feel like there's a responsibility
for call of duty war zone sort of
keeping that genre healthy almost
well we're always going to look at how
we make sure we're delivering top
quality experiences right so if
it's out there and it's got call of duty
in the name
right we're going to continue to think
about what's next how do we keep up
leveling that experience and making it
player-centric that's always just going
to be
the guidepost for us but you're right i
think now
given how interconnected
and dynamic the call of duty brand has
become
we have to be sensitive to components or
aspects or expectations of communities
that might have been
just much different or smaller frankly
prior to war zones dominance and
takeover
and the way that it's captured such
attention so i love that you know
personally i think there's so much we
therefore can do to have a bigger canvas
on which to paint so to speak
but with it you're right comes new
expectations new ways of thinking about
creative new ways of thinking about
connecting seasons
um and what we need to deliver for a war
zone experience
let's say around you know a season four
coming up here
has its own intricacies has its own
dimensions
um that might interplay differently than
what
will show up for the core premium cold
war
audience right all within the same
messaging framework or creative and
narrative framework so
we love that i mean we wouldn't have
done it if we didn't think we couldn't
um deliver in a world-class way but
you're right it
it adds more uh conversation around
community expectations and behaviors
and speaking of that fourth season
coming up what can what can fans
expect from this season yeah it's it's a
packed one
we've got a lot uh coming for players
across both cold war and war zone you've
got new maps you've got new operators
and your weapons
i love personally the narrative arc of
satellites now
crashing onto the scene and you know the
way in which we're just going to
continue to keep the content fresh
that's really the whole strategy here is
just keep giving players reasons
to come back uh come come and play
and and create that re-engagement in a
much more consistent manner
and war zone affords us an ability right
to stretch
um in these ways and keep refreshing the
content
at a seasonal level in addition to what
we see in our
major mainline release cadences so it's
fun to do it and i think season four is
going to have something for everybody
in many ways and with all the structural
organizational execution level
challenges and opportunities that come
with running not
one but multiple call of duty games
these days
at what scale are you sort of pushing
forward with with them all
is there sort of a defining force or a
singular game
that you're focused on or is it sort of
spinning all those plates at once
um well you know i think it's it's a
little bit that we become
our own biggest competitor in many ways
right
because call of duty has scaled so
tremendously
in a way that most brands not just in
gaming but also in entertainment often
aren't playing
at that type of dominant level all at
once
so yeah it certainly invites you know
complexities
to keep pumping out top-tier engagement
top-tier experiences year-round but
we're well positioned to do it i think
it speaks to the health of the franchise
that you know there's there's dynamism
sort of happening and firing on all
these different cylinders
you know specific challenges come with
the territory of trying to be
a true mega brand but that's part of the
appeal
in my opinion is that you know we we
play big and and we love
trying to set our own records and then
break them all over again so it's
it's it's an exciting time when you
think about it through that lens how
much of the
the health of of war zone and call of
duty mobile
do you feel is tied to that annual
release because obviously that's a huge
time of year for you over there and it
brings in a lot of players but are
each individual call of duty games now
strong enough that they can sort of
stand on their own
or how much is that yearly release
really pushing forward the
the separate games i think there's no
question that in many ways
what cod mobile's doing in and of itself
and then what warzone is doing sort of
in and of itself with its own community
and its own inflection points and then
certainly with what mainline is doing
you could make the argument that
they stand on their own merit in many
ways just from the sheer scale
of who's pouring into them but you know
i think the magic
is how we found the synergies creatively
i think season 3.5 that we just came off
of our
80s action heroes event is a great
example of that right like you really
saw it light up
not just in cold war but within warzone
and then even cod mobile bringing some
of those assets and
ways to play so you felt like you were
having a sort of franchise-wide
experience regardless of which door
you chose to pour into and it it really
translated
um with major success for us so they
certainly have their own strategies and
they certainly have their own nuances
because you know the play space and just
the community
intricacies are going to be different
and you need to be sharp about that
but at the same time i think the oneplus
one equals three
power of call of duty is that we can be
both specific and customized and
really enterprise wide to position the
brand as you know something much more
than just a one note type of experience
i'm really glad you mentioned the action
movie editions as well because i
absolutely adored that but i want to
know is there
is there more so action movie staples
in the mix is this sort of collaboration
between brands and already existing
franchises
something that you want to do more and
do you have any in the works
whenever it makes sense you know it's
all it always comes back to strategy
we're not going to just do something
because it's it's cool to do
or it's expected to do it's got to make
sense it's got to happen at the right
time
um and you don't want to sort of again
be one note for
tripwire on on just because it's worked
before you should do it over and over
again right and so
i think there's really careful
consideration around the power
of those types of partnerships and you
know as you mentioned it's awesome to
hear that you enjoyed it
and whether you enjoyed playing as rambo
or john mcclane and nakatomi tower like
that felt
in many ways on brand and another reason
to re-engage with call of duty right and
so we're always just going to think
about
the timing of those partnerships the the
why behind doing it right
and as long as there's a massive focus
on
fun great game play i want to drop in i
want to drop in with my friends so this
is going to be socially
you know connected for me um then
certainly it's something we're going to
take a look at but
we're always going to think about does
it make sense in a broader scope and
strategy before we just sort of
um rolled them out um in in too much of
an expected way
if there was no objections there was
there was no speed bumps in the road and
you could choose
any franchise that you could drop into
warzone purely your choice your favorite
no one could say no to you what would
what would it be i
i don't even think i'm allowed to answer
that question i'm sure the phones will
ring if i picked a
picked one but i will say as an
80s kid i am kind of signaling a little
bit of my age
um i loved it and in terms of season 3.5
and while i grew up watching a lot of
die hard so i was expecting to want to
really go that route like rambo had my
heart it was just the one
it took the cake um and so you know i
love that i think that the multiplicity
factor of that was was very cool too and
so
we'll we'll take that into consideration
and and we'll keep seeing what we can do
with it
all right well if you're taking requests
i'm a big fan of fifth element i know
you've already done bruce willis but
fifth element or great one demolition
man that'll make someone on our staff
very happy if you put them in i love
both of those suggestions
noted this uh this obviously very much
speaks to the evolution
of call of duty but now it's evolved so
much
to from the call of duty that we we knew
three four five years ago
now it's evolved so far has its main
competitors
shifted somewhat who do you feel is the
the main competitors in the market at
the moment for you you know it's a great
question and the reason
i love the question is because the brand
has stretched in all these different
ways
whereby the competitor set is actually
really
really
dynamic and wide-ranging and sometimes
the competition is really ourselves and
i don't mean that with any hubris i just
mean again
because we're playing in all these
different spaces that oftentimes you
don't find
one singular brand being able to do or
want to do as
sometimes it's really just about how do
we want to
you know manage our own success here i
say that too because
even coming up the ranks from the
esports side and competitive part of
call of duty
right like a lot of the vision there is
competing with sports
and entertainment properties and not
just top tier esports but really the
nba's the nfl's the world
so call of duty sort of entry into these
different
discussion points around who are we
competing with it really depends on
what part of the franchise we're seeking
to light up
the other thing i'd say though is like
competition is good you know
like the more that gaming is becoming
this more transformational
industry worldwide i think it's just
good for call of duty it's good for
esports it's good for
entertainment it's good for events so
you know we
while we are always going to look at the
competition we also sort of welcome it
because all boats certainly shall rise
with you know
the innovation that's just pouring into
the industry as we're seeing it right
now
now you've come from the esports side of
call of duty
um can you speak a little to how to the
importance
of of esports to to cod
uh well of course i'm a little biased
when i say that it's very important you
know but
i say that because these are the lebron
james of our sport
you know and and while that may be lost
on traditional let's say mainstream
culture in certain respects i think what
call of duty is doing to really
change the narrative around not just
professional competition but world-class
production
world-class broadcast events world class
ticketed events where you can go in and
have a call of duty experience
and also see the best of the best in the
world the other reason i say
it's important is because when you think
about how much our player
base has just expanded right and
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
people worldwide playing
the fact that you know our esports
community not only is
engaged as as avidly as they are but
they have to be so
tremendously good just statistically
speaking to be able to consider
themselves
a pro and i think that often gets lost
in the conversation of how good these
guys and
women have to be ultimately to compete
in call of duty just given the franchise
scale so it's something that i think we
love because it extends
people's attachment now i can tune in
and watch call of duty and have an
affinity for the brand
in addition to dropping in and playing
but i also you know i think it's about
giving
pro players the respect that they've so
rightly earned
and really putting them on on the map as
is truly the stars of tomorrow
not just in gaming but in sports and
entertainment more broadly
and this is very much the time of the
year where people including myself are
chomping at the bit for more more call
of duty
but can you actually share any details
when you're actually going to start
announcing the next call of duty
because we're too excited to sit still
at this point
i hear you i do not believe i am at
liberty
to to share more details um and
uh i don't want to get the slap on the
wrist
this early in my role as gm
but i will say there are great things
coming
and it's i think the reason we all feel
super energized about being a part of
call of duty right now because
you know the the days ahead just look so
promising and so exciting and
sledgehammer games is working on on the
next release and
it's gonna be a tremendous tremendous
thing um so we're excited to share more
details here
um as we get closer to prime time well i
greatly appreciate you spending a little
time with us today
and everyone watching when we do hear
news
about more call of duty we will bring it
to you so make sure to like the video
subscribe and stay tuned for more
content johanna thank you so much for
joining me
thank you
uh
you